Hi, my name is Riva
and I'm a linguist
who uses R. Seven years ago, I
tried to learn R and I failed.
I wasn't sure where to start
my R journey so as someone
with a background in the humanities,
I thought the best option was
reading a book.
I wanted to make one
of those cool plots
with a great background
that I've seen around
to communicate some results.
So I picked a book that promised
me that I will learn the most
important elements of R.
On page 99, I was still
reading about defining
classes and methods,
trying to understand
what an array was
and how to multiply its
elements but hadn't done
anything with real data yet.
The problem I think
were my expectations.
I was expecting
learning resources
that help me say
things with data
but all I found
were description
of rules that didn't make much
sense to me as a beginner.
It was very difficult
for me to see
how I can use these rules
with the data I have
and how I will jump from
these abstract descriptions
to, for example, making a plot.
It felt like trying to learn a
second language only by reading
a grammar book and
not by interacting
with actual human beings.
The thing is that learning
a programming language
has many similarities with
learning a second language.
But what does this mean?
How can this idea be applied
to the design of learning
resources or when choosing them
to guide your learning path.
And how can you take
this into account
when developing a
package for example.
First, let's talk
about learning.
Not everyone learns
a second language
with the same purposes.
The same happen with
programming languages.
I fail learning R the first
time because I wasn't the expected
audience for the book I chose.
At the moment, I just
wanted to be another user
not a programmer.
Not everyone is learning R to
be a linguist or a grammarian
of the language.
There are surely people that
want a deep understanding
of how the language works.
And those are the people
who are contributing
to its development.
But there are tons
of people that
just want to use R to do
things like making a plot,
or running statistical
model, or creating reports.
I failed the first time
I tried to learn R
because the book I
chose for learning
was the equivalent of
a grammar book of R,
descriptions of how
the language works
and the names and purposes
of all its different parts.
And as a beginner or someone who
just want to learn the language
to communicate
your data to others
that is not what is more useful.
What you need is something that
works more like a textbook.
Textbooks for learning a second
language always start the same.
You learn how to say Hello,
how to introduce yourself,
and some simple sentences to
communicate meaning to others.
Even books for learning dead
languages have this approach.
I had to learn a
little bit of Latin
as an undergrad
and the first thing
we learned was how to ask
someone, who they are,
and how to respond
to that question.
I even learned how to
insult someone in Latin.
A language in which the last
native speaker
died centuries ago.
Textbooks start this
way because they
are built around people needs for
knowledge not our own language
rules.
In textbooks, you
learn first what
you can do with the language
not how the language works.
In language teaching, this is
called a communicative approach
and it's based on the idea
that learning a language
successfully comes through
having to communicate
real meaning to real people.
Throughout the different
lessons in a textbook,
you learn new words and
structures and new context
where to use those
words and structures.
The grammar rules behind
those real life examples
are only explained after
you learn how to use them.
And if and only if it's really
necessary for you to know them.
In textbooks, scaffolding
work as a spiral.
You learn something
in one lesson
and then come back to that
content in the next lesson.
By now showing more ways
to use what you learn,
how to adapt it to
different situations,
and how to combine the
words and structures
you know, in your ways.
It's like copying and
pasting and then adapting.
You learn how to use a new
language structure like,
how to ask a question.
And then you learn how to
adapt it to your own needs,
to solve the problems
you're interested in.
Its this ability to adapt
the language structures
to new situations,
that makes us flexible users
in both natural languages
and programming ones.
For example, we first learned
how to create one type of plot
using all the default settings.
And then we can
back to that content
to add more complexity
to the association
like mapping more variables,
using different geoms,
or making annotations.
And we build those new
skills over the ones
we learned previously.
This copy, pasting,
and adapting is also
the strategy we
use with examples
we find in Stack Overflow
or RStudio Community.
We bring to our
scripts something
that work in another
context and then try
to figure out how to
adapt it to our own needs.
Sometimes we're
not even sure why
it didn't worked but after
doing it a couple of times
we start inferring what is
going on behind the scenes.
You don't need to know
all the grammar rules
to be understood in a language.
You don't need to know the
name of all its structures
to be a competent users.
Even native speakers don't
know the name of all the parts.
You probably don't
know what a paratactic
or a hypotactic clause
complex is but you definitely
know how to use one.
If you're a native
English speaker,
you know how to
correctly pronounce
every case of two O's together
in words like moon, book,
floor, and flood.
Something very, very difficult
for us not native speakers.
But you probably don't know why
they're pronounced differently.
The adults who raised you didn't
read your grammar book for you
to acquire your native language.
They didn't teach you
the grammar rules.
They talked to you
and let you talk.
They probably read you books.
You sung or sang together.
You did things with words
progressively more complex.
In the same way, you
don't need to know
all the rules of a
programming language
to be able to do things with it.
What rules do you need?
The ones that can help you
achieve the purposes you're
seeking.
If you need to customize a
plot in a very precise way
because the default options
are not what you need,
then learning how a
thing works in ggplot
is relevant; not before.
If you need to work with array
then learning what they are
and what kind of things
you can do with them
is relevant; not before.
One more thing about
textbooks, they usually
have learned our personas.
If you're learning a language
because you want to travel,
the first chapters
will probably show you
how to get along in
the airport and ask
for directions in a city.
If you're learning the
language because you're
going to study abroad,
the first chapters
will probably be
about students trying
to find something
in the campus
or dealing with
University bureaucracy.
The same happens with
programming learning resources.
Fortunately in the
past couple of years,
a lot of online resources
have appeared to learn R
in other programming languages.
And many of them are focused
on the needs of specific users.
So all the data and
examples are connected
with what those specific
users need to know.
So taking into account
the communicative approach
when teaching
programming language
involves: Doing real things
from day or page one.
Building complexity as a spiral,
revealing rules after you know
how and when to use them, and
all the ones that can help you
achieve what you're looking for.
And take into account who
your learner personas are.
In the last couple of
years a lot of R resources
have been created taking into
account these principles.
Learning resources that
let you experiment first
and then build the explanations.
Books that show
you the whole game
first and then explain the
details behind every step.
Publication that had in mind
different learning personas
with different
backgrounds that show you
how to do relevant things with
relevant data for your field.
But hey, what about
the other books?
The ones that
explain how R works.
Well, those actually
a very cool books.
I'm a linguist myself so I
really love grammar books.
But for both natural and
programming languages
they're not the first step
to approach a language
when what you want is
to learn how to use it
and how to communicate
with other people.
But is this
communicative approach
only relevant for people
teaching or learning R?
What about programmers?
What about people
developing packages?
Well, thinking
back at development
from a communicative
point of view
can also help us in issues
like developing more error
messages and documentation.
Let's take a look at
error messages first.
Whatever you are
learning, having feedback
is the kind of thing that
can help you improve.
This applies to
any human activity
from sports to cooking, from
meeting to language learning.
Having this in mind,
let's take a look
at two error messages
addressing the same problem.
We all have been here putting
one instead of two equal signs
to filter a column.
This is the error message
you get in base R.
It says, error unexpected
equal sign in and then the part
of the code where the
unexpected equal sign is.
Error message here
is pointing you
where your mistake is but there
is no clue on how to solve it.
Why is the equal
sign unexpected,
should I put something else?
And if you're not
an English speaker,
there is even more enigmatic.
Pointing errors is not the
same as giving feedback.
To learn from your
mistakes, you not only
need to know where the
error is but you need
some clues on how to solve it.
So next time you
know what to do.
Let's take a look at the
message for the same error
but using the filter
function from dplyr.
The error message says, error
problem with filter input 1,
Input 1 is named.
This usually means
that you have used
one equal sign instead of two.
Did you mean country two
equal signs is Chile?
Run rlang::last_error() to see
where the error occurred.
This message let us know
what the problem is,
its probable origin,
a suggestion how
it can be solved,
and if and only
if you want to know
where your code fail,
how to take a detailed look.
What we have here is feedback.
We not only learned the
origin of the problem
and how to solve
it, but also how
we can take a deeper
look at the code
to see where the error occured.
And if you're not
an English speaker
you can put this
on Google Translate
and we'll get something useful.
These couple of extra lines
in your function code
can make the life of
many people easier.
And help them feel in
a way they can learn.
Giving useful feedback
is the best way
to learn how to
overcome difficulties.
And this is something we do
all the time when someone is
learning our native language.
If you don't understand what
they are trying to communicate,
you usually say things
like, sorry, did you mean--
and try to rephrase what they
said to check if you understand
correctly their intention.
We don't go around saying people
lack of subject-verb agreement
or misplaced modifiers.
We don't do that
because it is not
really helpful for learners.
It's more effective to give
cues on how to fix the problem
and show how accurate
version might look like.
So if you're a package
developer and want people
to be happy users
with your package,
you can think about
how your error
messages can give guidance.
But error messages
are not the only part
of a package that can adopt
a communicative approach.
Let's take a look
at documentation.
Function documentation is great.
Sometimes you forget
the name of an argument
and taking the whole
page can allow you
to solve this kind of issue.
But do you think you need
to know the actual name
of the function you're after?
Otherwise it's kind of useless.
What if you know the
problem you want to solve
but not the name of the function
that can help you solve it?
Function documentation
are like dictionaries.
They have the
definition of the words
you can use in a
programming language
but we don't learn a
language by memorizing words
from the dictionary.
We need to learn how to use
the words, in what context
they are useful,
what kind of meaning
can we construct with them.
What if you don't know the
name of the function you need?
What if you know what
you want to achieve
but not what functions can
be useful for that.
Well, here comes vignette.
Vignettes are awesome resources
to describe the problem
that your package is
designed to solve and to
show people how to solve it.
They are a great
resource to show
how to do things with your
package with real example.
And they are easy to find
using a search engine
so they are also a great
way to promote your package.
In a vignette, you can
explain with details
the different categories
your functions are divided.
How you can coordinate multiple
functions to solve problems.
And show extended examples
that people can copy,
paste, and adapt to
meet their own needs.
The best part is
that vignettes are
easy to create using
the usethis package.
With usethis::use_vignette(),
you can create one.
So thinking of error
messages as a way
to give feedback to the
users of your package
and writing vignettes that
explain how to do things
with functions you
create, are great ways
to think about
package development
from a communicative approach.
Two closing remarks: is really
R the best programming language
to learn?
Isn't Python better
or what about Julia?
With programming language
happened the same as
with natural languages.
There is no one intrinsically
better than the other.
The best programming
language is the one
that can help you solve more
effectively the problem you
are trying to solve in the
context you currently are.
Sometimes things
like processing time
or a number of lines of code are
important to take into account
but sometimes they're not.
And only what is easier
or faster for you
to write not the computer to
process is more important.
And sometimes it's more relevant
what programming language
your audience can understand.
The same happens with
natural languages.
Right now, I would really
prefer to be speaking in Spanish
but it's definitely
more effective
if I speak in English.
Why?
Not because of
any characteristic
of English language itself.
Actually for this
subject in particular,
Spanish is way more precise
because we have more words
to speak about language.
We make distinctions
like lengua,
lenguaje, and idioma
all of which have
different and precise meanings.
So I need to use
more words in English
to explain those concepts.
But right now, being able to
convey one message to a broader
audience is more important than
lexical variety and precision
that Spanish offers
to the subject.
So which programming
language to lean?
The one that can help you
best solve the problems
you're interested
in and that allow
you to speak with
the people you're
interested in communicating
with at that moment.
And the same way as
with natural languages,
knowing more than one allow you
to communicate with more people
and do more things with words.
And this leads us to the
second closing remark.
Communication and community
has the same etymology.
A communicative approach
in programming languages
is important because it can help
us build stronger communities
where everyone can be
part of the conversation.
New people learning
the language can
offer new and
diverse perspectives
and we should cherish that.
There is no one correct way to
learn a programming language
but there are many
things that we
can be done to make it more
effective and enjoyable.
Failing to offer people
opportunities to learn
in an easier way or
thinking that the only way
to learn a programming
language is the hard way
is not only kind of
a gatekeeping issue
but it's also dangerous.
Because the most
dangerous thing that
can happen to our
natural programming
language is not having a
vibrant community of users
to keep it alive and evolving.